الى حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا وقالت هيئه
الاركان الاوكرانيه ان عرضا من المدنيين
سقطوا نتيجه اطلاق القوات الروسيه 49
صاروخا باتجاه المواقع الاوكرانيه واتهمت
القوات الاوكرانيه روسيا بشان 37 غاره
بينما اطلقت اكثر من 60 مقذوفا من رجمات
الصواريخ على المناطق السكنيه خلال الساعه
الاربعاء والعشرين الماضيه واكلت هيئه
الاركان الاوكرانيه في بيانها ان القوات
الاوكرانيه حافظت على مواقعها في محاور
الايمان وافديفكا ومارينكا وباخمت في
مقاطعه دوناتسكا كما صدى هجمات في محيط
كوبيانس بخار كيف وكاله القوات الروسيه
تحاول تحقيق اختراق فيها ومن جهه ثانيه
نقلت وكاله سبوتنيك عن مسؤول عسكري روسيا
للقوات الروسيه صدت 9 هجمات للقوات
الاوكرانيه في سباتوف وكرازن اليمن وقتلت
اكثر من 150 جنديه كما دمرت مدرعتين
واربع مركبات عسكريه مصفحه واضاف المسؤول
العسكري الروسي وان ثمانيه من افراد الحرس
الوطني الاوكراني استسلموا خلال عمليه صد
الهجوم وسلموا انفسهم للقوات الروسيه
ينضم الينا من كوبيان مقاطعه خار كيف شمال
شرقيه اوكرانيا مراسل الجزيره مازن
ابراهيم مازن هجمات روسيه تقول هيئه
الاركان الاوكرانيه اوقعت تسعه قتله تسعه
واربعون صاروخا 37 غاره 60 مقذوفا روسيا
ما هي التفاصيل
في الواقع زين العابدين دعني ابدا من هنا
من اهميه هذه المنطقه من كوبيان التي
اتواجد فيها والتي باتت احد المحاور
الرئيسيه للقتال في كل هذه المنطقه
الشرقيه
عمليا كوبيانسك باتت محطه الانظار يمكنك
ان تشاهد حجم الدمار حجم القصف الروسي
المستمر الذي يلحق بهذه المدينه بشكل يومي
لماذا كوبياس لانها اصبحت المركز الرئيسي
والمحور الرئيسي للهجوم الروسي على طول
هذه الجبهه لاسيما الممتده من خاركاف
لوغانسك عمليا موقع مدينه كوبيانسكو موقع
استراتيجي هو يقع بين مقاطعتين بين لوجانس
وبين خركات تحاول من خلالها القوات
الروسيه التي كانت قد خسرت سيطرتها على
هذه المدينه في سبتمبر الماضي تحاول ان
تستعيدها مجددا لذلك تقوم بقصف مدفعي
وصاروخي من ناحيه ومحاوله تقدم كبيره
لقواتها على طول الجبهه المحيط بمدينه
ونتحدث عن نحو 8 كيلومترات تبعد القوات
الروسيه عن هذه المدينه في محاوله للضغط
والوصول اليها لانها في ضمن هذه المدينه
يقطع نهر شرير وتحاول القوات الروسيه
الوصول اليه كي يشكل عائقا مائيا وما يعرف
بمنطقه حمايه لمقاطعه التي تسيطر القوات
الروسيه على نحو 95% منها في هنا في
كوبيانسك القصف يستمر يكاد يتوقف عمليات
محاولات التقدم الروسيه مستمره وباتت
المحور الرئيسي اليوم في كل بيانات
القياده قياده هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه
وايضا البيانات الروسيه تشير الى محاوله
التقدم على محوري الايمان وكوبيانسك في
هذه المقاطعات الشرقيه تحديدا لذلك الوجود
هنا في هذه المنطقه يكتسب اهميه كبيره من
خلال التاكيد وفق هيئه
القوات الروسيه كي لا تشكل امرين الامر
الاول محاوله ضغط والتفاف من هذه المنطقه
باتجاه دنيتك والمناطق التي ما زالت تسيطر
عليها القوات الاوكرانيه وتقدر بنحو 30%
من من مقاطعه والامر الثاني يرتبط بمحاوله
تامين وحمايه القوات الروسيه المتواجده في
مقاطعه لوغاس لذلك هذه المنطقه باتت محور
كل الاشتباكات وكل محاولات التقدم
والتراجع بين الطرفين شكرا جزيلا لك من
كوبيان مازن ابراهيم